[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros comenzamos
a 10 años de la primavera árabe unos
levantamientos populares que cambiaron
el rumbo de una región entera france24
les comparte un reportaje sobre cómo
nuestra cadena cubrió en 2011 esta
sacudida en el magreb y en medio oriente
en esta edición de reporteros repasamos
los orígenes del movimiento su
cronología sus consecuencias y las
lecciones que han quedado iremos desde
túnez a egipto pasando por libia y
bahréin donde millones de personas
salieron a las calles para desafiar el
orden establecido con varias demandas
poder beneficiarse de elecciones libres
en una verdadera democracia y del
derecho a elegir su gobierno dejando
atrás el conformismo y la pacífica
[Música]
un acontecimiento de una magnitud sin
presidentes
una sacudida que tomó por sorpresa a los
autócratas que han estado en el poder
durante décadas la primavera árabe
un movimiento de revuelta que encendió
parte del magreb y medio oriente en 2011
desde túnez hasta bahrein millones de
personas han desafiado la prohibición
queremos lo mismo que en túnez egipto
queremos elecciones una verdadera
democracia queremos elegir nuestro
gobierno
a menudo arriesgando sus vidas
les presentamos el relato de los
primeros meses de estos acontecimientos
históricos el 14 de enero de 2011
túnez está sumido en la confusión
las protestas masivas piden la salida
del presidente tunecino
que lleva 23 años en el poder
[Aplausos]
[Música]
manifestó
van a dar buena barça
y con paciencia un mes antes un joven
comerciante de verduras se prendió fuego
en sidi buzid después de que la policía
confiscara su puesto de verduras
su acto desesperado provocó una protesta
generalizada contra el régimen
autoritario de ben alí
el 13 de enero promete un cambio para
túnez
el 7 de noviembre prometí que no me
presentaría a la presidencia de por vida
todavía no lo sabe pero acaba de
pronunciar su último discurso como
presidente lee con atención el querido
lo que me llevo de ese día lo rápido que
sucedieron las cosas porque esta mañana
nadie podía predecir que al final del
día el presidente habría abandonado el
país y finalmente a las 6 y 40 de la
tarde fue el primer ministro el que
habló en directo por televisión para
decir que el presidente ben alí ya no
estaba en condiciones de desempeñar sus
funciones y fue entonces cuando nos
dimos cuenta de que estábamos viviendo
un día histórico
te quiero
esta mañana mi jeep se siente por fin
orgulloso de tararear el himno nacional
orgulloso de su país orgulloso de los
tunecinos que han logrado lo impensable
es 15 de enero el primer día después de
ben alí
el expresidente huyó la noche anterior
así que sin más
este contable decide llevar una prueba
si podemos los tunecinos también podemos
un mensaje inofensivo pero imposible
bajo el antiguo régimen
y medita aunque hay una opinión
benítez
soldados policías agentes encubiertos me
lleva una hora caminando por la calle
sin que nadie le detenga
siempre ha vivido en túnez para él es un
milagro
y
[Música]
bienvenidos a esta edición especial
dedicado a la revuelta egipcia un millón
de personas se manifiestan en las calles
de el cairo y alejandría desde hace ocho
días diez días después de la caída de
ben alí la protesta popular se expande
en egipto en el cairo la inmensa plaza
tahir se transforma en un bastión de la
revolución
la víspera el presidente mubarak
apareció en la televisión para anunciar
su marcha en seis meses demasiado tiempo
para sus opositores debe irse ya nuestro
país no funciona hay corrupción en todas
partes la policía y el gobierno nos
están extorsionando estamos
completamente asfixiados y no podemos
vivir más quiero decírselo a todo el
mundo el nombre de mi familia tus seres
queridos y mis vecinos no se trata sólo
de una revolución de los jóvenes sino de
toda la gente que sufre
[Música]
el presidente egipcio ha atendido sus
demandas cambió el gobierno nombró un
primer ministro que a todos les gusta
omar suleimán es una persona que ellos
pidieron tenemos que ser pacientes con
nuestro gobierno
la atención se incrementa veo a dos
personas peleando violentamente
estamos tratando de evacuar a los
heridos detrás de los tanques y cómo va
a quedar la duda
luchamos
[Aplausos]
los partidarios de mubarak arremete en
contra la multitud a lomo de caballo y
de camello
los opositores al régimen están
enfadados y han decidido defenderse los
adoquines de la plaza tahir sirven para
repeler a los atacantes lo que nos pasa
aquí es culpa de hosni mubarak nos ataca
quieran matarlos a todos
estos son agentes del gobierno no son
verdaderos restantes
proyectos
las tensiones complican el trabajo de
los periodistas decenas de ellos son
agredidos por la multitud y la policía
seguro
he querido visitar a los partidarios de
mubarak en aras de la objetividad y aquí
está lo que queda de la camiseta que
llevaba puesta en ese momento como la
hemos sufrido la sacudidas de un sistema
que está en crisis hubo una ejecución
simulada en un momento en que estábamos
boca abajo manos atadas detrás de la
espalda uno de los soldados accionó la
culata de su kalashnikov alguien intentó
romperme la pierna izquierda mientras
estaba acostado alguien trató de
aplastar la rodilla por detrás tras tres
semanas de protestas sin presidentes
hosni mubarak dimite
egipto entra en una nueva era a su
íntimo se está celebrando una gran
fiesta popular aquí en la plaza thahrir
todo el mundo a mi alrededor canta baila
hay elecciones de todos los orígenes y
todos están unidos hoy para celebrar la
salida del presidente mubarak
otro lugar otro ambiente en trípoli
[Música]
desde lo alto de este balcón el coronel
gadafi arenga a la multitud
[Aplausos]
ante las cámaras dice que no le preocupa
el enfado que retumba en el país
le harán
en irak afganistán o pakistán matan a
los terroristas a los extremistas
islámicos y la otan también los combates
para nosotros es lo mismo
pero en realidad libia se hundirá
rápidamente en la guerra civil en
cirenaica en el lado de brega los
soldados aprendices fueron a luchar
contra el ejército libio
para muchos es la prueba de fuego estos
hombres son peluqueros banqueros
estudiantes etcétera libios de a pie que
se alistan de la noche a la mañana para
una guerra improvisada
los más viejos han prestado el servicio
militar y sacan sus viejas fatigas
otros van a la guerra en vaqueros y
tenis con un cuchillo al cinto
los insurgentes quieren llegar a trípoli
[Música]
donde la guerra es aún un rumor lejano
es en un banco donde se observan los
métodos del régimen para conseguir el
apoyo del pueblo de gloria él sabe cómo
hacerlo hoy distribución general de
billetes es dinero del petróleo 500
dinares en efectivo es decir 300 euros
eso es el salario de un mes para el
bueno así que las ventanillas no dan a
bases un girasol
pero el camino a la capital es peligroso
hay que pasar por misrata
hasta la última posición arrebatada por
la rebelión a los hombres del coronel
gadafi
aquí los combates se desarrollan casi
nunca se casan por casa y dejan a una
ciudad totalmente devastada
en misrata ha comenzado la gracia del
francotirador gadafistas
tenemos que estar rápido porque el
francotirador es los edificios altos
para tenemos que correr en los que se
ponen el casco antiguo cada tragaluz
cada cruce es una trampa mortal
[Aplausos]
[Música]
está mejor
pero al final de la calle
[Aplausos]
estos hombres acaban de asaltar este
edificio en el que aún flotan los
colores verdes del coronel kadhafi este
edificio ha utilizado donde se
atrincheró un francotirador al igual que
muchos otros que se exponen en todo el
país por toda la calle taipei por
distrito
en agosto de 2011 es la marcha final
hacia la capital
se forma una brigada de civiles para
dirigir el asalto su nombre la katiba de
trípoli
dos meses más tarde el coronel gadafi es
asesinado en la ciudad en los suburbios
desierto en condiciones que no han sido
esclarecidas hasta el día de hoy
la primavera árabe también se extiende
hacia el oriente en yemen unas protestas
sin presidentes exigen la salida del
presidente saleh pero esta revuelta es
reprimida con sangre
el 27 de enero el ejército dispara
munición real a la multitud
[Música]
y matando
quiero formar parte de los que protegen
a la gente
aquí la revolución dio paso al caos ya
la guerra que sumió al país en una de
las peores crisis humanitarias del mundo
en manama bahrein la plaza de la perla
se ha convertido en un símbolo de la
protesta contra la minoría suní que
gobierna al país
aunque también de la represión violenta
contra la revuelta pacífica
docenas de personas serán asesinadas
él es firme firme por esto apenas un mes
después del inicio de la revuelta el
vecino saudí proporciona apoyo logístico
y militar la revolución va de mí no
ocurrirá la plaza de la perla es
destruida para borrar todo rastro de la
protesta
en siria también es una minoría la que
está en el poder
los alauitas del clan asad una dictadura
gobernada con puño de hierro por el clan
asad desde hace cuatro décadas donde el
menor signo de protesta puede enviarte a
la cárcel en marzo de 2011 no hay
indicios de que el país vaya a ser
arrasado también y sin embargo unos
jóvenes sirios son detenidos por
criticar al régimen
algunos son torturados las
manifestaciones estallan en derá y otras
ciudades del país el gobierno responde
con sangre a las demandas de cambio la
guerra civil estalla y la estrategia que
está implementando actualmente el
régimen de bashar al-assad es la de la
asfixia y paso a paso les dejan algunos
focos de resistencia para ganar tiempo
porque no pueden estar en todos los
frentes así que se centran en las
grandes ciudades con su poder a que son
emblemáticas
para llegar a viniste tuvimos que entrar
a siria de forma ilegal cruzar las
montañas para finalmente encontrarnos
con esa ciudad en el poder del ejército
sirio libre que el gobierno no ha podido
someter
los insurgentes controlan la ciudad pero
no pueden proteger el hospital nos vemos
obligados a ir por la parte de atrás
para evitar ser visto de ajó tierra
la doctora liu
los nuevos el médico que nos recibe
corre enormes riesgos desea hablar de
forma anónima está tratando a él seguido
de forma clandestina
este hombre fue alcanzado por la
metralla en la cadera mientras se
encontraba en la puerta de su casa en el
90% de los casos los heridos no tienen
nada que ver con la resistencia la
protesta o los revolucionarios la
mayoría de las veces son personas
alcanzadas por proyectiles mientras
están en su casa una carro o tienda puro
a los heridos soy médico asumo las
consecuencias a medida que pasan los
meses la represión aumenta en 2013 se
volvió más cruel cuando el ejército
sirio lanzó su primer ataque químico
contra la población en los suburbios de
damasco en 2011 la primavera árabe fue
una esperanza de libertad para el mundo
árabe-musulmán diez años después el
panorama es desigual solo túnez ha
realizado una transición democrática
aunque frágil egipto tuvo su primer
presidente elegido por la vía de las
urnas
mohamed morsi de los hermanos musulmanes
pero un golpe de estado del mariscal al
sisi volvió a sumir al país en un
régimen autoritario desde la muerte del
coronel gadafi en libia se enfrentan
facciones rivales que a pesar de los
intentos de paz parecen irreconciliables
el sirio bashar al-assad sigue
gobernando en damasco su país destrozado
es ahora un campo de ruinas
gracias por compartir con nosotros esta
edición de reportero recuerde que puede
ver este y las anteriores emisiones en
nuestra página web más 24 punto com
hasta la próxima semana